u.s airways flight 901 is one of the
longest domestic non-stop flights i
believe it was from anchorage to i would
assume since it's it's us airways it was
to philadelphia and arthur berkowitz
knows exactly how long it takes down to
the minute because he had to stand for
most of the flight when he returned to
philadelphia last july why would anyone
stand for that long you would ask louis
well he was next to a morbidly obese
passenger who was as we know can happen
as i've talked about spilling into his
personal space making it impossible for
him to sit in his assigned seat the
flight was full you've dealt with this
lewis haven't you yeah so have you i've
dealt with it many times and um he said
that the man's size required both
armrests to be raised up and allowed for
his body to cover half of the other
guy's seat so
this meets two of the three requirements
lewis and you know the requirements for
a passenger of socks
spilling onto another seat armrest can't
be down